il veut du
global cheech eskom global championship
2022 compétition au combien attendu sur
sur internet avec coisy mans
tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde
alors on aura pas de alireza ambulants
mais on va avoir du maxsym aujourd'hui
qu'on va suivre je vais aller récupérer
les caméras les joueurs sont pas encore
sont pas encore là je vais lancer
je les récupère et je vais je vais les
cadres et au début au début de la partie
ce qui va faire très plaisir on a
on va
attendre que ça commence
il est 13 heures j'ai pas encore les
parties je vais vérifier que le live
soit bien parti parce qu'on a du délai
c'est les règles danse dans ce tournoi
pour limiter les possibilités de triche
donc on attend on attend que ça parte
donc je pourrais pas vraiment réagir
avec le chat
on est quand même quand même très
heureux
j'ai toujours pas les caméras qui arrive
c'est un problème
et je vois toujours pas les parties
lancé
c'est un autre problème bon c'est pas
très grave
ce n'est pas très grave
on va prendre on va attendre pas trop ce
qui se passe on va attendre
c'est censé commencer à 13h mais bon il
faut quand même la mise en place et
c'est pas quelque chose de simple
bon on attend
on attend et je peux pas réagir au tchad
donc
va être anti peut on va attendre en fait
j'ai pas trop pas grand chose à rajouter
c'est quoi la compet c'est le global qui
assiègent comme global championship
compétition compétition sur internet
compétition sur internet ya pas ou quoi
comme prix à gagner il ya beaucoup
d'argent je crois qu'il ya plus d'un
million de dollars de prix donc c'est
assez énorme
après
ouais là c'est les 32e de finale
maxime qui va qui va affronter
eduardo ricke to ride zagat
et qui après affrontera le vainqueur de
samse vian contreras smooth vannes eux
et à la pour le moment on attend on
attend de pouvoir avoir les caméras on
attend le début le début des parties
je suis en train de cliquer en fait vous
voyez pas méchant train de cliquer pour
avoir les games
donc on va on va on va attendre et
désolé de ne pas pouvoir réagir avec le
chat comme je le disais il ya une
minutes de délai
c'est très compliqué pour stream avec un
délai comme ça parce que ben je peux pas
répondre à vos questions et c'est vrai
que quand il se passe rien comme ça
c'est la ouate complexe de meubler mais
bon
on attend
je fais peut-être allait me prendre un
truc à manger j'ai pas eu le temps de
bouffer c'est peut-être juste le moment
en fait de partir manger
à je ne sais pas j'ai aucune idée de
quoi vous dire en fait
là celle-là je suis je suis perdu
iam lost comme comme on dirait sur sur
les stream en anglais
c'est bien à raser 3 0 vois tu vois j'ai
pas j'ai pas vu et je vois pas les
parties donc c'est complexe
c'est bien qu'il ça m'étonne pas un
sévillan qui est beaucoup plus fort que
cela ne
les ya pas les ja pas les scores
l'affiché je vois pas les scores des
matches mais je sais pas aux assises
vanneuse je le vois ça devrait la gagner
3 0 on va voir on va voir on va voir
on va
se lance
il doit y avoir un truc qui se passe
parce que je suis pas redirigée vers le
salon avec les joueurs et il ya ça doit
ni topalov qui joué juhan john kerry au
pire on n'aura pas les calmes c'est pas
non plus gravissime
c'est pas non plus gravissime
j'ai du mal à rennes c'est bizarre de
stream et avec autant de délai parce que
du coup pas j'ai peut-être plus qu'une
minute crois que j'ai une minute 20 du
coût en tout et c'est bizarre ce que je
vois réagir à des trucs que j'ai dit
avant en tout cas j'ai pas allégé pas
les parties
on peut regarder topalov sadoine y est
on peut en attendant alors attendez non
là c'est pas ça
alors on est en train de rejoindre la
salle pourquoi ça n'a pas marché quand
j'ai fait ça ça aurait dû marcher
les caméras y en a plein on va essayer
de récup
cela va être compliqué c'est complexe
alors attendez on va essayer de bien
faire les choses déjà
et de redmond wa récup
ok bon déjà ça c'est bon maintenant il
nous reste plus qu'à avoir la bonne
partie et les bons matches
donc j 1 toutes les cases avec mv lmv
littorine zagat etc mais le match
n'a pas commencé on va ça c'est topaloff
bon là c'est au pas la fsa doit ni
j'essaye de regarder un pourquoi le
match n'est pas commencée
alors maxime on peut le mettre en caméra
donc ça c'est déjà une première bonne
nouvelle
mais je vois est parti sur une chaise
comme en tout cas
je vois les autres on va déjà récupéré
maxime
maxime qui doit avoir
envie de jouer après après le petit raté
à l'asim que field
et de se qualifier pour la finale qui je
crois aura lieu à toronto si je dis pas
de bêtises
je crois que c'est toronto
déjà on va pouvoir voir maxime on va
bien le remettre
maxime on l'a
mais il tord itza
pas sa bonne came attendait un
ca c'est un problème ah
[Musique]
ok
donc maxime à bien les blancs
et ça y est la partie est lancée
alors on va récupérer les touristes
agacé une sicilienne alors il peut y
avoir les coûts qui vont arriver en
rafale ça je vous le dit d'entrée
les coûts peuvent arriver en rafale
donc c'est un peu ce qui va se passer
pour pour l'ouverture et la fin de
partie et je vais récupérer la can du
touriste aga qui vient à peine d'arriver
malheureusement je vois
ça va être compliqué d'avoir la caméra
de face parce qu'elles sont
ouais
mince on a pu la bonne came ouais ça va
être compliqué parce que le truc ouais
pas trop comment faire en fait il faut
autant les
voix on va on va
ok
ok c'est bon on va on va réussir à le
faire attendez une petite seconde sa
demande est
de réagencer les caméras
comme ils sont arrivés en retard tous
les deux en fait ça nous a mis enfin pas
tous les deux un des deux je sais pas
lequel ça nous a mis ça nous a mis dans
une sauce en fait
ça nous a mis dans une sauce
ad on est bon
turisas gars qui est d'origine
papier vénézuélien en fait je crois
sa caméra est pas top top donc maxime
avec les blancs est ce que vous voyez
bien tout
j'ai pas pu voir la partie moi j'aime la
repasser rapidement puis en plus ça nous
permet de la revoir coup par coup parce
que c'est vrai que les cours arrivent à
peu en grappe
ok bon c'est un genre de sicilienne
cannes et maxime qui envoie du g4 g5
voix maximy vacui qu'un de toute façon
il ya quatre parties donc
donc il ya le temps
le match
on a le score
que vous voyez bien voilà on est parfait
on est nickel on va suivre cette game
maxime tu veux ramener le carillon des
sinko
tranquillement tranquillement
il va y avoir le cas à venir trois pions
des 5 c'est magnifique ah bah il va
falloir clic pour maxime
bah là il fait sa petite tête de maxime
qui sourit
il va juste cliquer en fait il va faire
tour ff4 je pense qu'il est venu pour
cliquer du touriste zagat qui cliquent
aussi un cdu 15 + 2 il clique fort aussi
au bras je crois trop allez hop
il en a absolument rien à [ __ ] de la
tacc d'ituri d'sa gars il est tranquille
il veut juste on voyait des punto
en fait il veut juste envoyer des punto
devant le roi et voir ce qui se passe et
s'assure un peu côté vénézuélien déjà à
faudra cliquer un peu aussi un côté côté
ituri gaga qui qui va juste se faire
défoncer en fait
je crois qu'il est espagnole il n'est
pas espagnol il est venu vivre en
espagne ituri zagat mais je crois bien
qu'il ait vénézuélien
rxh 5 à 5 à 4 façon il va falloir
rockets frérot il me fais quoi là
bonelli eduardo
annoncé aux terribles ou tir ithurritze
zagat bonelli et son prénom c'est
eduardo ou edward a comme comme vous
voulez
joli prénom eduardo d'ailleurs
il n'ya pas fuir ou en fait à fuir ou je
crois qu'il a il joue plus trop les
tournois sur internet il joue peut-être
le championne tour mais
c'est pas trop ce pas trop sa tasse de
thé
les tournois les tournées internet
internet firoud il essaye surtout de se
concentrer sur son objectif majeur qui
est de devenir champion du monde
d'échecs et il veut pas perdre de temps
avec avec ce genre de distraction il a
probablement raison c'est
voilà il a un objectif qui est clair et
il mais il met tout ce qui est en son
pouvoir et toute son énergie dans la
réalisation de son objectif alireza et
il est jeune c'est il a le le parcours
tracé pour devenir champion du monde on
voit que maxime un peu encore un risque
il en jet lag parce qu'il est rentré à
paris où est ce que il n'a pas trop
dormi mais maxime qui est pas qui a pas
sa tête des grands jours mais ça devrait
suffire à lhassa bayonne oui là c'est
vraiment vraiment tranquille tranquille
mais ça devrait ça devrait suffire
me dit on devrait interdire le cas ce
qu'on peut nous souffler les coups de
dents
ouais il a d'ailleurs peut-être une
remontrance de larbitre parce qu'il
vient de l'enlever le casque
c'est pas faux ce que tu dis après il ya
tellement de manières d'avoir d'avoir
les coûts je pense pas qu'on puisse
réaliser une fouille anale des joueurs
comme ça a posteriori enfin pas par
internet je pense que c'est quand même
assez difficile donc pour le casque oui
c'est une facilité pour avoir quelqu'un
qui parle de dents mais d'un autre côté
bon il peut aussi avoir une tolérance
là-dessus
aléas
côté ouais ouais il a gagné deux cent
soixante dix mille balles et il se hisse
il se concentre vraiment sur son
objectif alireza c'est ça moi ça me
paraît être une bonne gestion de
carrière personnellement
du côté d'ali reza il a que 19 ans il
est déjà numéro quatre mondial son
objectif c'est la qualification aux
prochains candidats et éventuellement
ben même un match de championnat du
monde alors la route c'est en un petit
peu entre ouverte en l'absence de magnus
carlsen
donc ça me paraît assez sympa
ça me paraît pas comme gestion là à la
question c'est rock h5 et click & click
les punto je pense qu'il to ride zagat
réfléchit pas forcément bon moment de
façon maxime lui va appliquer il en a
absolument rien à [ __ ] il va juste
envoyer les pions
et maxime qui voit essaye quand même de
se concentrer
là le vénézuélien bras là c'est trop en
cinq minutes sur ce coup
c'est trop en fait
tu peux pas à tort réfléchir est bon il
est pas content mais monte à une
position de merde c'est vrai fallait
réfléchir avant sinon
c'est complexe à ce qui nous fait
historique zagat la position paraît
difficile 1 h 5 g si ça arrive vite si
tu rock pas tu vas te prendre du f4 haut
dans la tronche à ses savates ouvrir le
centre
très changeante en fouille a ouai mais
bon c'est quand même un sujet important
des échecs d'heure j'ai répondu à une
interview hier d'une journaliste je
crois pour le soir belgique et
j'espère bien que mes propos seront
retranscrits à 100% et qu'on parlera de
fouilles anales dans ce dans ce journal
j'ai bien sûr évoqué
le sujet qui fâche dit bon voilà il
faudrait ce qu'il faut que les joueurs
se mettre en slip avant les parties
peut-être ainsi c'est pour la sécurité
du jeu
il va falloir le faire
ils m'ont paru assez réceptifs
cavale cette pendant maxime va cliquer
h5 en fait c'est sûr
il va envoyer le pion h5 directement il
va pas réfléchir très longtemps
j'imagine
ouais lecavalier a eu 7 bras qui colmate
de trois cases mais
il a fait cavalier f5 bon ça a l'air
très bien aussi cavaliers pro f 5 e f ça
touche le foufou prend pions prend ici
ce qui arrive est sûre rock qui va faire
h5
ça peut ça peut faire un stop ce match
ça peut vraiment faire un deux et demi à
1 2 me
avec un maxime à 10 % de ses capacités
mais ça suffit
ce sera plus difficile au prochain tour
contre sam sevian sam ces gens il est
vraiment dangereux il et 2007 en longues
et c'est un joueur rompu aux
compétitions internet
mais mais ça suffira pas il tout riggs à
gaza suffira pas il avait peut-être
mieux à faire de son après midi
et donc là il va envoyer h5 maxime c'est
sûr bon un petit peu d'eau
après il ya des scanners maintenant plus
besoin de fouiller les scanners je suis
pas sur sigmund arrco
1 le petit rock qui est parti et maxime
bas qui va qui va envoyer le pion h5
j'imagine et qui va aller lui ouvrir le
roi
prend son temps et là encore quand même
12 min 43 vous voyez bien les pendules
d'ailleurs c'est suffisamment grand
c'est une question que je me posais
c'est une question que je me pose est
donc je vous la pose ce coma sur mon
retour régis est vraiment petit mais je
commence à avoir des problèmes de vue de
loin en plus donc c'est catastrophique
et il envoie h5
il semble être premier quand même
maximin parce qu'il va pouvoir créer
avec g6 la rupture sur l'époux une toge
pour ouvrir les colonnes devant le roi
du touriste à aga
miakhaïl 32e aujourd'hui à où il ya
quatre partis aujourd'hui c'est
normalement ça va durer ça va durer 4h
quand même
peut-être 3 6 maxime réussi à turbo
écrasé son adversaire et signera quand
même quatre heures de jeu et après ce
seront les seizièmes de finale puis les
8e
et je crois que c'est lorsqu'il ne
restera plus que huit joueurs que ça
jouera
sur un échiquier ray est réelle la
grande finale
très belle compétition je vous
recommande de regarder il ya des beaux
joueurs
là autorise je sais pas ce qu'ils
regardent en fait faut regarder l'écran
eduardo
il faut quoi elle joue sur une tablette
c'est parce qu'il fait en fait oui ou
l'écran de son ordinateur est très petit
en fait il fait l'inversé hikaru et le
de regarder au plafond
bon bah il s'est juste déconnecté
abbas est magnifique
ouais il ya des gens qui sont connectés
reconnecter comme d'hab
ça crée des problèmes
non
allaient ils sont recadrer les joueurs
qu'est ce qui fait en fait historique
zagat mais je pense juste cliquer en
fait
il faut jouer
à ce jeu il n'a pas compris en fait
eduardo
à la caméra de maxime maintenant qui est
décalée
des joueurs qui se déconnectent il se
reconnaît que ça décale tout le monde
est-ce qu'on peut attacher
maxime il doit pas trop comprendre ce
qui lui arrive il joue contre un
adversaire trop faible
joue sur sont-elles cherchez pas je sais
pas sur quoi il joue en fait
ils torride zagat
essais je vois pas de dauger passe à
came de dos dont québécois y ait eu deux
trois coups là qui sont arrivés
il a fait reprise f5 écarts et les
dessins qu
il a pas l'air bien là il va se prendre
un f2 pardon j'ai mis ce clic il va se
prendre un f6 non juste
m6 où j'ai ici soit il est en partie
catastrophique en ituri zagat
maxime maxime qui se dit je vais
repartir en siesta
il est vraiment facile maxime dans cette
partie y'a même pas de suspense en fait
ce que les joueurs voient la cam de
lotois il les voit
ouais je sais pas mais il s'est qualifié
après un don qui mérite d'être là mais
la marche est trop et trop haute
la ceiba c'est terrible parce qu'en fait
l'intérêt quand on joue les rocks opposé
c'est d'être le premier qui touche le le
trio de pions adverse et la maxime le
touch avec apsys partie extrêmement
facile de maxime
c'est peut-être maxime qui va passer par
la cage par la case fouilles après une
partie comme ça
il faudrait peut-être mieux perdre en
fait pour maxime
il va pas être bien donc cavalier
qu'at-il touche un peu pense pas qu'on
mette la dame aux quatre pour pas donner
un tempo avec des cinq mais un juste un
coup comme dame g4
peut-être juste 1 dames g4 faut prendre
cette dame f5 g6 qui peut arriver aux
dames g4 si on prend un système f3 et
non bon enfin il ya tout qui gagne
d'alger cats a vraiment l'air fort
après maxime a raison de prendre son
temps ce qui a peut-être des variantes
où il réussit à échanger les dames et
ils donnent que 1 ou 2 punto shdm et la
finale sera gagnante pour maxime
ça joue vraiment très facilement
bah ça joue vraiment très très
facilement via
l'ouverture de l'est des colonnes devant
le roi noir est trop avancée par rapport
à ce qu'ils t'ont riddes a gagné en
train de faire
le film rêve il est visé ya trop d'écart
de niveau en fait
il est trop au-dessus maxime après faire
attention de pas s'endormir quand même
mais globalement il est c'est le niveau
au-dessus maxime
c'est trop en fait
c'est juste trop
dames 4 pas des cinq direct il va faire
j'ai six avants et des cinq après
juste dire tu veux pas te mettre dans du
d5 malheureusement je ne peux pas réagir
avec le chat trop de délai
mais d'un métro d'alger cade du coup est
plus logique en quelque sorte que du
coup ci fait g6 battu
tueur perdra pas de temps quoi tu te
mets pas dans du d5
dell va peut-être faire des cinq quand
même pour essayer de faire 4
way le problème c'est qu'il lui manque
deux ou trois tempo il aurait les pions
à 4 et b4 il serait en train déjà de
faire à 3 il aurait peut-être dû contre
jeux et des chances mais là il ya trop
de retard il va se prendre courage
quatre tours h un pion projet sisters
prend 1,7 ça va trop vite en fait
ça va mon trop vite
je pense qu'il va attendre pour prendre
maxime parce qu'il veut pas laisser la
case f7 pour la tour
la seule gloire de la position noir
c'est peut-être cette tour à sept qui
défend h7
est f4 qui défend g6
ok il a mis un vrai cette app défensif
torride zagat ce qui a un beau miracle
de sa part il a vraiment raté son
ouverture
et pourquoi et du délai avant un délai
d'une minute
et très franchement je n'arrive pas à
comprendre si on a les caméras en direct
des joueurs ou pas parce que si on n'a
pas les caméras en direct
ça semblerait faire aucun sens parce
qu'en fait les gens de toutes façons
peuvent voir la partie sur ted.com
events
donc je dois dire que je suis assez
surpris
à moins ce qui est un délai ici par
rapport aux
je vais faire un test attendez on perd
là la position de minutes mais je vais
faire un test
est-ce que
ouais en fait on peut regarder la partie
ici
ce qui est d'ailleurs peut-être mieux
on va
ça je vais recadrer mais au moins on
aura pas on n'aura pas les coups qui
arrive en rafale
ouais c'est peut-être pas bête
on va faire un petit un petit changement
ok on va on va faire un petit décalage
là maintenant
et ça nous permet à voir les coûts en
rafale c'est mieux en fait et du coup on
est complètement en direct sur l'autre
truc en fait ils ont mis un délai
je vais régler le truc j'en ai pour deux
minutes
façon là on voit bien que la partie
est complètement gagnante pour maxime
faudra quand même faire attention à ne
pas de pas se faire contrer mais on voit
que le roi noir est beaucoup trop faible
je vais vous récup les pendules on va
suivre comme ça en fait ça va être mieux
pour pour nous
ça va être beaucoup mieux pour nous
ça évitera d'un le petit décalage
ça explique pourquoi sur la caméra en
fait j'avais
ça explique pourquoi sur la caméra y
avait un petit décalage
donc on voit que maxime à toutes ces
pièces sur le rock il a sacrifié une
qualité pendant qu'on faisait ce petit
ce petit changement en f4 mais bon on
voit que le roi noir est aux abois
là la menace ça doit être fou pranger 6e
d'un match 8
et de toute façon il ya trop de trop de
pièces sur le roi
du joueur espagnol
qui est dans le dur ça va faire 1-0
instantanément
plus de deux minutes 22 pour pour
ithurritze zagat qui va bientôt devoir
laisser la première partie est peut-être
ses illusions avec
là c'est tout est trop faible en fait
côté côté noir ya f4 f5 aussi qui peut
partir
puis il ya plus de temps
trop de problèmes maxime en plus qu'à 6
42 dans une position pareille
c'est trop s'est nettement trop donc là
et menace arrive menace vous prend qui
on prend d'arâches 8 wife sept tours à
je suis trois ou six daims prend 8 puis
tourcoing f7 tour français s'aide pardon
donc je avait eu cinq
pour défendre et attaquer fou et 4 dames
c4
alors maxime attention maintenant s'ils
bougent le fouillis fait changer les
dames
derrière content de ses couilles torride
zagat là
mais bon maxima une position en or
maxime a une position en or
failli l'empêcher f4 aussi adam prend
1,4 ok il a mis deux trois barbus
bien joué à 10 tours ids hague a
bien défendu de la part des touristes
haga maxime qui essayent a péniblement
de se réveiller
je sais pas s'il veut jouer un coup
comme cavalier d2 mais il fera il fera
dam des cats probablement et to ride
zagat
et sa dame peut encore revenir en f7
dont il fait cavalier à 5
donc sur dame c'est cette île doit
vouloir faire food et 5
et sur damas cette tour d un
probablement pour vraiment enfoncer le
clou sur la casse des 5
il n'est pas bien eduardo
mais il lui reste plus qu'une 15
après difficile de juger de cette partie
des d'edward ops qui s'est mis vraiment
il est vraiment été très vite très mal
donc cavalier f3
alors il veut quoi il veut
cavalier c4
déjà sur fou prend il veut dame prend
tout reprend et touré un math et qui
avait laissé quatre cavaliers h4 cavale
et des six tours des huit
food et 5,3 fuite
c'est ça qu'il veut
au kef où des 5,3 et fuite il va devoir
faire
équipe
3 donc un relief 5 force et
cavaliers f5 a l'air d'être le seul coup
comment est ce qu'on gagne un prix
cavalière 5 c'est sûr qu'on peut le
faire
je vous assure que j'ai pas le gain aia
qui a rallié prendre comprend g6 fillon
prend et tourage suite maths c'est
terminé qu'est ce que c'est bien joué de
la part de maxime
vue à la vitesse de la lumière
c'est fait g 6e tour h8 mat du coup il a
fait tout un foin f3 et on prend trois
cavaliers f5
ils essayent d'attaquer le 3
y'a quoi matériel mans 1 2 3 4 5 et un
pion de plus pour maxime
et une position écrasante
et ben voilà ça à faire punto ça va
faire 1 0
ça va faire 1 0 pour maxime je vois pas
maxime raté une finale aussi simple
elle a pas l'air difficile celle là
il suffit de monter la ive 4 pour
enfermer le cheval carrément
on n'arrive même plus à lui trouver de
caser sa bande on va écouter ça fait 1 0
pour maxime
et ça fait très plaisir
je sais pas quelle qu'elles sont les
scores dans les autres matches
peu
je peux trouver sa niche entre 1,2 et
qui allait avec machete je suis pas bien
attendez et voyez le truc c'est que mme
en fait je vois je vois tout petit
j'ai pas les rêves des autres matches
mais ça fait 1 0 pour maxime c'est le
plus important
je vais je vais le trouver je vais
trouver pour moi les scores des autres
matchs instantanément sur le events
danis a fait nul dans la première
à nantes ponk rate of
s'est tendu
position est très ça va probablement
faire annuler
ighirri contre joue auncun ça a fait nul
à
imagine que les parties recommencent
dans une dizaine de minutes je sais pas
maxime tranquille en maxime sans forcer
il est beaucoup trop fort en fait
je sais pas si eux
si robin saïda l'horaire de la prochaine
partie
mais la lave et là par les plats la
partie était trop facile pour maximin
sait on à l'impression
juste après l'ouverture c'était déjà
c'était déjà quasiment terminé
on va
le prochain
oh bah oui pub de trois minutes j'espère
j'espère une belle pub là de toute façon
de toute façon là on est en attente 1 je
pense que dès que ça repart j'aurai la
partie automatiquement de maxime
ces coccinelles et doit coccinelle où es
tu
bon
j'imagine que ça doit recommencer à 45
ça m'étonnerait que ça recommence à 14
heures ça me paraît très trop long
il est passionné j'espère que maxime est
fort surtout comparativement à maxime
c'est trop en dessous en fait
c'est trop en dessous 1 la différence de
niveau est trop grande et en plus
historique zagat il a un style qui
convient à maxime
donc c'est trop en fait
c'est beaucoup trop
ouais non c'est pas c'est pas sympa que
c'est pas de bol c'est que de toute
façon
il ya trop de joueurs au dessus du
touriste haga en fait dans ce tournoi
pour qu'ils aient pu espérer aller loin
mais bon c'est toujours compliqué c'est
toujours compliqué dans ces cas-là il
salué ce conflit kate lloyd in 10 k
ok ça reprend dans cinq minutes ah bah
c'est parfait ça va cliquer
je pense que dans une heure et quart on
a terminé un ça va cliquer victoire à la
deux et ça va faire une petit nul
pleutre à la 3
merci au revoir cinq your good bye
c'est pas porcine et oui tenant ces
coccinelles
ou es-tu
coccinelle
tarbes à coccinelles et d'un
important
coccinelle important de savoir où elles
sont
d'ailleurs pour régler mes problèmes de
cochenilles j'ai vu qu'il se vendait des
des larves de coccinelles qui les bouffe
en fait coccinelle aide aux baoulé
cochenille qui peuvent se faire
coccinelle da tout moment voilà on va
savoir où elles sont les coccinelles
et ce qui tient à confirmer et 2007 en
fait c'était confirmé avant même le
données schengen
c'était un peu un bate en fait
je pense
ouais on met les enfin je le connais
c'est pas un mauvais joueur en vrai
c'est juste qu'il est dans le même
registre que maxime genre maxime aurait
eu beaucoup plus de mal contre un par
avion
comparativement à 6 si on veut parler
si on veut par l'échec si on veut parler
style de jeu et c'est par avion poserait
beaucoup plus de problèmes à maxime là
on est contre un joueur qui est
nettement plus faible que maxime et qui
est dans le même registre
donc
non c'est dur
pour voir là alors non parce que ça va
reprendre donc on va regarder le direct
tu pourras avoir en rediffusion si tu
souhaites ou alors vous simplement à la
revoir tour à la partie tu peux sur sur
twitch revenir en arrière sur un direct
coccinelle
oui tu
allez on
à partie on attend la suite donc ça
devrait recommencer si les calculs sont
bons ça devra reprendre à 42
il essaye de garder quand même quelque
chose de dynamique c'est plutôt bien ça
va enchaîner un
ça va enchaîner it will and chain
ils vendent
de coccinelles sans elle pour qu'elle
reste chez toi vu la modification adn
c'est moche ça en vrai ça c'est moche
mais larves de coccinelles c'est pas mal
pour tuer les cochons ni
au lieu d'utiliser l'insecticide
richesse est très écologique de tuer les
cochons ni au final
quoique les cochenilles à l'heure elles
détruisent ton arbre je sais pas comment
ça se passe à ce niveau là
ça les coccinelles il faut que tu as un
truc qui te supprime les coccinelles
derrière
peut-être french use un
maxime qui est tranquille ça va jouer
est-ce que ça va jouer la gagne avec les
noirs pour maxime ou pas
coccinelle coccinelle
on attend alors les calmes ont de
nouveau changé
touring a key buy est aussi en phase
maxime va voir les noirs à la prochaine
du coup faucon
modifié
cris
m c'est beaucoup de la coccinelle de
chine qui dispose des coccinelles
european ok
merci pour l'info 5 you for the
information
1 ça repart un marx et ça repart
il n'a pas l'air bien eduardo aller
maxime on gagne encore une petite
d'euros
c'est pas mal sur le banc en vrai ça
marche pas des coccinelles ne sont pas
assez nombreuses et finissent par se
barrer mais elle se barre pourquoi en
fait
est ce que si tu passes du french news
elle resterait pas
là de salalah meta en fait c'est de
prendre les coccinelles et de passer du
french news
devrait repartir très bientôt
allez on est impatient là quand même
ils disent que ça reprend 1,45
il ya deux airs et un thé hockey
1 c'est non
sais pas pourquoi papa
aucune idée allez il faut envoyer les
game là hop hop hop
depuis qu'on forme vraiment des échecs
où il faut joueurs coaches je sais pas
one only pas confortablement un
pas assez fort hein attention
non non c'est un peu trop en dessous
c'est le niveau en dessous il torride
zagat même si
il a pu flirter un parent va pas dire
est que les 2007 mais il était à 26,50
plus
aller sa part on va voir ce qui va jouer
avec les blancs
ils to ride zagat
ait en deçà
voir ce que maxime répond ça va pas
jouer la prépa des candidats ça c'est
sûr
quand pourquoi ce tournant au hasard
rien bah c'est le che score global
championship donc c'est un tournoi qui
pas qu'ils comptent pour rien en fait
c'est qui
compte pour ça en fait j'ai pas trop
comment dire
il est suffisant à lui-même en fait
ça il n'est pas intégré dans un dans un
plus gros tableau ou quoi en fait il est
facile et la cua il vit suit sa vie
donc là c'est une ouverture un peu
bizarre avec le h4 ça retombe dans des
genres de benoni avec h4
c'est un peu bizarre est difficile à
expliquer parce que c'est pas des coups
normaux mais en gros tu espères retomber
dans une structure benoni etc le h5
cause car je crois trois psycho soit
fort
après la question
à quoi sert tournoi
quand je disais il se suffit à lui-même
en fait
ok maxima
qui a une position correcte ici va
falloir réussir à taper sur les cases il
veut faire a6b cinq c4
jouer sur sa majorité
ouais ça fait ça ça retombe dans une
baie noni bizarre où exactement
peut laisser la porte ouverte qui n'a
s'écoule alors ferme la porte n'est pas
de pub pas de souci non non il y en a un
ça va là on est en train de regarder la
game est on est on est parfait
en carélie h7 il va développer les
pièces s'est départi aa3 résultats
ont ils développent en fait
parler ses positions qui sont vraiment
bizarre
je re à première vue c'est vraiment
mieux pour les noms pour les mois je
préfèrerais jouer avec les noirs en fait
mme en fait c'est mieux pour les blancs
je t'ai fait tellement de trous mais en
fait tu contrôles bien le centre
tu peux pas faire petit rock qui peut
pas vraiment faire grand roque mais ça
joue vraiment sur l'espace
c'est quoi la tentation 1 millions de
par la dotation est énorme mais c'est
fin c'est juste un toit qui compte pour
lui-même quoi
comment il se met à l'abri ben justement
fautif des fois ils font même roi et feu
dans ces trucs là
et tout revient et il garde le roi un
peu bizarre leur tour en
h16 avait plu est fou de cases blanches
après elle pourrait repasser par âge 3 7
tours c'est un peu particulier
c'est très bizarre a joué
ne jouez jamais ce genre de choses un
conseil
après l'hymne donc
patronné douay pour la patronne qui a
pas l'habitude qu'on commande des
tournois comme ça en plein en plein
après midi
qui est revenue spécialement aujourd'hui
mais qui suis un peu
on n'a pas qui suis un petit peu
en cavale d1 alors qu'est ce qu'il veut
faire avec car elle est d un j'en sais
rien parce qu'il doit vouloir revenir en
trois pour a lancé quatre mais le
cavalier va arriver eux 5
ça a l'air assez catastrophique
ça a l'air d'être très mal joué paris
torride zagat
maxime qui cliquent juste ou tempo
ouais
et ils contrôlent les contrôles c4s a
vraiment l'air
oui c'est tromper ithurritze zagamé
après ces genres de position le redis il
adore les blancs mais concrètement
comment tu joues si tu fais petit rock
adam prend h4 si tu fais grand roque tu
te prends b5
soit c'est très dur un cahier quatrième
français 4 france et 4 mai à
palmarès il vient de jouer il vient de
jouer quatre ou cinq coups pour pour
revenir au même
donc c'est un peu bizarre
cc
c'est juste mal joué en fait
vingt ans
non très très beau format magnifique
avec les tours qui passe comme ça
surtout la finale qui va être sympa
quand il restera huit joueurs
surtout la finale lorsqu il restera huit
joueurs là la phase finale finale va
être cool là on est encore dans les
qualifs
mais mais la phase du premier os
sur l'axé du 2 au 7 novembre de mémoire
ça va être vraiment sympa
donc à 5 mai à wayne on là le problème
c'est que prennent prix torride drag en
fait ce qui n'a pas de casque pour son
roi et que lecavalier h7 contrôle g5 je
pense maxime baffert fou et 6 il va
juste aller ramasser le pion en fait
c'est tout à fait dans le style maxime
esque
c'est le style maxime esque
cavaliers f6
c'est bien aussi parce que ça attaque 4
il veut provoquer f3
et peut-être qu'il fera fou b saint
caprais pour échanger le fou
fou baisse
c'est ce qui vient de se passer
non c'est juste
c'est trop malgré la connexion de maxime
qui est pas terrible il a que une barre
vous pouvez pas le voir mais maxime a
qu'une barre de connexion
mais ouais non c'est trop trop dur trop
dur à jouer qui avait les décès at on
dit généralement que dans les p o neal
il faut échanger deux pièces et là c'est
ce que maxime a réussi à faire
il a échangé pile poil 2 pièces
et du coup il est il est extrêmement
bien
je pense qu'il va prendre ses 4 et
cavaliers 17 personnellement
ça a l'air d'être la meilleure solution
ça a l'air
meilleure solution
belle position en tout cas
maxime qui fait qui fait le taff
maxime qui fait le travail dans cette
partie
et qui a et qui a bien bien maîtrisé
l'ouverture dans les structures benoni
quand on échange de pièces après on
commence à voir toutes les cases la
raison c'est qu'on a plus le problème
d'espacé un côté
côté noir on a moins de pièces
et du coup là il va pouvoir rentrer sur
toutes les cases noires alors c'est un
peu contre intuitif de dire que les
cases noires que le fou de cannes noires
et le bon fou parce que maxime allais
pions sur cases noires et son adversaire
les pions sur case blanche donc le foot
des blancs en f4 est censé être le bon
fou et le fou g7 est censé être le
mauvais fou mais là le truc c'est qu'en
fait on voyait entre autres ou sur cases
noires et le fou peut pas tout les
combler s'il y aurait la même position
avec un pion aux cinq la position serait
vraiment bonne pour les blancs mais le
problème c'est que comme ya pas deux qui
ont eu cinq dans le fouillis va pouvoir
naviguer sur les cases noires
et c'est ça le problème de la position
des blancs
c'est pour ça si mais mieux bon là si ça
fait 2-0 le match et coisy terminé 1
le match serait quasi terminé
2 0 avec deux parties à jouer à 7,8 ou
reid zagada rang caméra
ali reza participants alireza lui se
concentre vraiment sur sur les tournois
réels
à l'aller noire importante
il est dans il est dans le dur
ithurritze zagat
après le jouer à l'ouverture était
intéressant mais
c'est trop
je vois haqqani torride zaghawa que vous
écrivez mais j'ai une minute trente de
décalage avec vous donc je m'en suis
rendu compte avant que vous l'écriviez
mais malheureusement le temps le temps
que je le fasse en fait il ya un
décalage trop grand donc essayer de pas
trop réagir dans le chat
c'est plus de poser des questions on va
dire plutôt général que je puisse y
répondre sinon le décalage est trop
grand
meiway lapin c'est juste que tu sais pas
où mettre ton roi si tu fais petit rock
adam prend h4 encore que la thyroïde un
proche quatre yeux rouges et 5 mais bon
là ça va être dames 5 1 qui va rentrer
pour dame prend b2 peut-être arriver
peut-être dames 5 faut être quatre dames
7 rouges et 5 après maxime peut aussi
faire ça hein en fait match nul pour
maxime c'est pas mal bon il faut aussi
s'il veut il veut en découdre mais match
nul ce serait pas
ce serait pas une mauvaise chose
ce ne serait pas un mauvais résultat
chez sia de ton en longues missiles tata
steel en janvier j'ai l'impression que
le calendrier vide en fin d'année
alors il va y avoir des compétitions
intéressantes déjà je crois que c'est du
25 au 30 octobre
ou c'est du 25 7 25 au 30 septembre où
en tout cas il va y avoir le championnat
du monde de 960 je crois que c'est du 25
au 30 octobre mais je me suis mis en
doute là
à
après y aura la finale de ce tournoi qui
sera du 2 au 7 novembre
donc qui sera qui sera aussi sympa et il
y aura le championnat du monde de
rapides et blitz fin décembre et il y
aura notre compétition l'exablate ceci
fin novembre mi-novembre
donc
il y aura quelques compétitions sympa
après ans l'ong
y aura weick en janvier fait le
calendrier très mal foutu un depuis
longtemps les tournois sont un peu
ramassé les uns sur les autres
mais mais ce sera ce sera en janvier
après on n'a pas encore l'annnonce du
circuit grande chaise tour qui sera
qualificatif pour le candidat l'année
prochaine donc on sait pas trop encore
et je crois pas qu'ils aient date encore
pour la coupe du monde ni pour le match
de championnat du monde d'ailleurs qui
sont quand même
important
ce que maxime 960 où il s'en fout je
crois qu'il aime bien mais comme les
qualifs je sais pas si les joues les
qualifs en fait
je crois pas avoir vu maxime jouer les
qualifications du 960
way maxime et maxime et tranquille à la
position est vraiment belle il va faire
tout reprend des six tours b 8 il va
taper en b2
il faut prend instantanément maintenant
il va reprendre de a j'imagine 32f
donnerait la case 5 c'est trop
ah mais il va se prendre ces terribles
qu'elle prend des six tombeaux jaj 4 et
dame prend 2,4 au cul oui bon ça va
faire 2 0 l'as
apparaît en revanche attention le match
contre séville en sera beaucoup plus
difficile là vous le sentez on est tous
très tranquille parce que la différence
de niveau est stratosphérique sont déjà
de base mais en plus cela la première
partie était déjà
très avantageuse pour maxime après à
peine cinq minutes de jeu bon et là la
deuxième partie il est vraiment en train
de faire l'écart donc il est vite l'idée
avec h4 mais maintenant le problème
c'est qu'ils donnent la case 5 et
regardez le cavalier j'ai 3 10 to ride
zagar il a pas de case il est pris dans
le pion
ce cavalier il est pris dans les poules
d'eau et c'est le carré de maxime qui
prend là la priorité
pourquoi pas qui fait pas le tournoi il
n'a pas voulu tenter la phase de qualif
bas qu'il aime pas les tournois sur
internet en dix minutes
ça reste pas il préfère pas joué
ils se contentent ils aiment bien les
blitz et les belettes sur internet il
n'aime pas trop les cadences plus longue
donc la whey maintenant on voit un ces
visuels maximas cavaliers qui est
magnifique en a eu cinq qui protège à
vii donc y aura jamais de jeu la case m6
elle est inaccessible pour le cavalier
il peut pas rentrer dessus donc les
noirs ont une case pour le cavalier les
blancs non et en gros ça va juste suivre
comme ça ça va être tout reprend des six
tours b 8 dames 17 tours prend b2 grosso
modo alors après on peut aussi passer la
tour peut-être en b 4 voire même en b3
gens faire tomber 8 tomber trois tours b
huit tombes est retombé 4 et dames
bessette ça pas que ça gagne tout seul
je sur est encore un petit peu au noir
parce que il ya toujours des magouilles
possible mais on n'oublie pas que c'est
maxime avec les noirs c'est pas la même
chose
il fait karelia sein du coup pour
essayer de revenir bon an mal an v rêve
de détroit
il veut revenir en d3 c'est un joli
chemin là prix pareils torride zag assez
bien joué et c'est ce qu'il fallait
faire
est tombée trois ça interdit cavaliers
detroit et on va ramener tourbe et 4
dames 17 comme annoncé précédemment
il a déjà à 0 0 avant le début du match
c'était dur pour historique zagat mais
alors là à 2 0 pour maxime
alors il commence par tours 1 pour
essayer d'amener la dame en bessette en
premier
maxime peut aussi jouer tour 8b 6 passes
et la dame puis tour bk je pense que
c'est l'option que maxime va choisir
la torah ira peut-être en a deux pour
défendre le pion mais bon
on va pas inventer
un suspense qui n'existe pas dans ce
match en ça que ça deviendra intéressant
à partir du match suivant je vous
remontre les autres joueurs dans la
partie de tableau de maxime
qui peuvent quand même
quand même faire mal
voilà on va regarder ça ensemble donc
voyez on a topalov ça doit ni à nom de
pont crac of
plutôt une partie de tableau qui serait
bien pour maxime topalov a aucune chance
contre maxime ça c'est sûr
ça doit ni non plus je trouve qu'il n'a
pas une phase pas eu une phase de
progression aussi intéressante qu'on
l'attendait donc les deux joueurs de ce
match là sont pas dangereux ponk rate of
j'imagine ça passe facile pour maxime
aussi crétion de style là encore même si
je ne trouve même plus dangereux que
topalov et sa douaniers à la rigueur
pour maxime topaloff est plus fort
intrinsèquement métaux pas là fait un
joueur qui convient à maxime comme un
gant je pense que le seul joueur la dent
dans les dents les deux deux premiers on
va dire car de ce quart de tableau le
seul dangereux ce serait anne hand après
au prochain tour
c'était pas sévir maxime
je pensais que j'ai vu dans le tableau
de ses biens en fait
pourquoi j'ai pas le bon tableau ici
je l'avais vu dans le tableau de ces
vian
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
pourquoi c'est pas le
à cause des horaires des joueurs en tout
cas il est censé jouer sévit au prochain
tour
abdou qui fait peur mais abdul doit pas
être dans cette partie de tableau
ont pas joué les quarts deux tableaux en
même temps à cause à cause des horaires
des joueurs
pourrait être deux fois ils devaient
s'être bien justement parce qu'en fait
c'est parce que les tables partie de
tableau joue pas je joue pas je joue pas
en même temps
les joueurs ça arrange sur les créneaux
bon et dans la partie qu'est ce qui
s'est passé dans maximum il pu en c4 qui
l'a doublé comme prévu il tape avec la
dame en a 7
c'est pas long mais si c'est le bon
groupe et ce que j'expliquais
s'est jusque là les le les scores sont
mis sur les scores en direct des parties
en ce moment et pas par groupe
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
giraud chat parce que j'ai du décalage
donc prochain tour cessé vian et après
ce serait qui
continuer à faire avancer sa position
très tranquillement
il peut échanger les dames il peut les
garder il peut peut-être essayer d'aller
des cas les vergers 4
ok c'est les bonnes derrière
celle even derrière qui pourraient voilà
ouais ouais ça y est j'ai le
le groupe et ouais c'est les bonnes mais
attention à théodore ou 1 j'ai pas quand
est-ce qu'ils jouent bien ils ont déjà
dû jouer en fait les bonnes et teodoro a
je suis perdu je suis perdue parce
qu'ils jouent pas en groupe donc c'est
complexe
théodore ou ça peut être un joueur
dangereux même si les bonnes et large
n'ont pas encore joué je crois
et donc
contre le vainqueur du groupe g
qui a pour sa part qu'il ya ding lira
donc et groupe g qui est plus fort que
le groupe de maxime
ont ils appris en f2 et remet la tour en
b3
cavaliers t1
on voit quand même la marche que maxime
a par rapport à un joueur à 26 50 il
remporte quand même c'est parti très
facilement
ya même pas de
absolument aucun suspense c'est grand
maître contre amateurs
la différence c'est trop quand
le match devrait durer trois parties 1 3
maigre partie
facile aide
il est facile a dit torride zagat
maxime air de bien se faire chier ben
c'est trop simple en fait pour lui quand
je vous disais le tour suivant contre
sam sevian il va le prendre très au
sérieux parce que c'est un joueur qui
est déjà en capacité de l'éliminer
alors maxime est loin devant mais bon ça
peut il ya bien un danger
c'est l'heure de la sieste ah bah oui 14
heures c'est l'heure de la sieste à un
très clairement
normalement il ya siesta cette heure ci
voilà il va pouvoir partir en siesta sur
les coups de 15h j'imagine je passe une
touriste zagat va vraiment tenter
quelque chose dans la troisième
s'il va laisser faire une nulle facile
parce que ça me saoule intéressant de
voir ça d'ailleurs
maxime qui prend b2 ils échangent contre
le pur à 4 mais juste regarder les pions
1 regardez ces quatre contre cinq les
mets en les bleus contre les verts ils
sont bloqués grâce aux cavaliers qui qui
m'a qui bloque le pion aux oeufs en fait
et du coup regarder les noirs ils ont le
pion c'est qu'ils avancent et les blancs
ils ont le pion de bloquer
une violation à 3m suffisent ils gagnent
oui
nul sur 11e et le match serait terminée
donc maxime est déjà plus fort et en
plus ils mènent 2 0
ça paraît absolument impossible pour
ituri saga mission impossible
pour l'espagnol le seul espagnol qui va
refaire son apparition
dans le monde du gaming
tomber 3 pour maxime
va probablement y avoir un tour c'est un
pour mettre le cavalier en c3
après peut encore sauver nul 1 peut-être
dans cette partie là évidemment maxime
peut plus perdre mais les blancs
papillon - tu bloques encore
ça doit être foutu mais tu as encore un
peu de nul dans ton règne
pour 3,1 éleveurs cavaliers c3 c'est le
seul coup
sinon c'est tout reprend 1,4 au prochain
mais quelle c3 il doit y avoir cavaliers
detroit
pour ces 2 qui avait les b 4 tours c1
ça défend encore pour ituri zagat
donc tour ces deux maxime va
probablement faire tour eu un échec 3 2
et qui a valu aux cinq retours
pas encore terminée
on voit d'ailleurs qu'il a à vous le
voyez pas les l'épisode chaise comme et
il a bien le drapeau vénézuélien encore
un historique saga sur 13 points comme
c'est chou elle bandide pour leur aide
de 16 personnes ça c'est dur est qui
vient merci à toi
ça sa chance envoyé un coup que sinaï où
es-tu on nous dit dans le tchat
ce qui peut tenter cavale pour aller
toucher des six
matchs à deux ennemis parce que ce en
quatre parties en fait
la cinquième je crois que c'est le tie
break il le laisse dedans
maxime qui peut échanger les tourelles
et faire car et les f2 qui a valu aux
quatre déjà
pour gagner un point d'eau c'est ce
qu'il va faire
non
et peut-être s'en va en faire un
deuxième j'avais laissé 3 qui avait les
prends des 5 et ça ce serait douche pau
et auch
ce qui a précipité simenon s'est fait le
design est fait pour pouvoir regarder
avec avec côté blanc mais c'est bien le
regard des côtes et blanc en fait
bref si c'est bien aussi un pion prend
cavaliers prend il va les prendre le
pouls une touche tous pareils
à y fait même à y croire 7 3 6
3 au 5
et ça en fait deux
et ça fait 2 0 maxime qui se lève et qui
se barre
ouais trop facile pour maxime
trop facile
même pas de frissons dans ses parties
les quarts
ouais c'est un gouffre même peut-être
2,3 gouffre qui les sépare et envoyer
tous risa gars qui est dépité
jacques il avait pas trop de doutes sur
l'issue du match l'a20
il n'y a plus aucun espoir
alors c'est pas mag aidons à la fin va
lire c'est un mort subite je crois
de toute façon ce sera pas important
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va pas avoir besoin de
savoir
parce qu'il y en aura pas
rajuste pas en fait
ces entrées contre maxime d'entrée du
web c'est la loi des têtes de série 1
c'est la dure loi des têtes de série
complexe
n'y allez web assourdi web voilà c'est
ça va être un match
cours je pensais qu'on serait ensemble
pour 4 heures
ça va ça va aller beaucoup plus vite que
ça pour maxime
il ya une appris ça ce n'est pas en
tuant à gagner le match non mais bon
quand tu viens dans un match tu espères
toujours mettre un ou deux boutons au
moins se fait à te faire un peu vivre et
à être un partout
après tu dis reste plus que 2 game je
peux faire quelque chose là 2-0 après
deux parties
tu espérais rien mais tu es déçu quand
même en fait tu
es déçu quand même
regardé la fin de
ces guelph en doublant comptera douze
photographes
la douce autographes avec les noirs donc
satan a fait fort
photographe c'est très très fort un
champion du monde de rapides
et donc y aura six minutes de pause
après la fin de cette partie là
entre nos dires bec avec les noirs donc
égale fendre il ya déjà 1 0 là c'est
pareil si ça gagne à 2 0 c'est déjà
terminé entre guillemets
tu sais pas ce genre de zéro un peu
mouvementée il se fait balader par wayne
exactement prisme je suis d'accord avec
toi c'est pas un 2 0 où tu as un peu
vivre et dans les partis c'est vraiment
ouais enfin table tu as même pas vibro
t'es quoi c'est vraiment un 2 0 très
facile
elle fournit la plus à ces temps ça va
perdre aussi contre contre abou stroff
ça à faire de 0,6 ici
c'est trop en fait
maxime qui repasse voir
en plus quel fendent
au delà d'une position qui est pas
simple à jouer au blanc il en plus mal
autant contre un joueur réputé très
bonne tactique
il va être il va être trop court boris
près bravo à lui d'en être quand même
arriver jusqu'ici
allez tu es 3d 2 et jouer pour f4 il a
encore une petite chance de sauver nul
ce qui serait déjà un bon résultat
évidemment
avant d'essayer de gagner pour le
spectacle faire nul rapide pour
économiser de l'énergie parle d'énergie
je pense qu'ils s'en fout un peu parce
qu'il n'ya pas de parti derrière
après dans ces parties là quand ça
compte pas pour le vélo etc déjà quand
ce même ça comptait pour le vélo tu
serais très pragmatique mais là si
l'adversaire te propose nul au premier
coup tu acceptes sans la moindre
hésitation
tu vas pas t'embêter à jouer pour jouer
en fait donc non
hélas hélas galfingue qui va pas pouvoir
qui va pas la tenir ça va faire de 0,6
dans ce match
calage également il doit déjà avoir plus
de 50 ans un boris
voilà c'est pas facile il faut prendre
une décision vite vite vite vite vite
cavale et prend ici c'est un joli coup
ce qui va la tenir boris et non
la à 2-0 le match est lui aussi
plié on va dire ça et maxime qui est
venu voir la fin de cette partie qui est
parti en pose donc normalement ça
devrait reprendre dans six minutes les
partis six minutes de pause 6 minutes of
pose
c'est ça six minutes de pause donc début
de la prochaine partie je pense à 14h30
parce qu'ils aiment bien commencé à un
horaire précis
on pourrait déjà bientôt
en arriver au bout de cette journée
un maxime expéditif 1
maxime expéditif
ça va commencer à devenir intéressant il
pourrait jouer au prochain match bon il
va jouer au prochain match à sam sevian
puis ça pour être après autour de levon
aronian puis peut-être dingli rennes qui
attendra maxime
en huitième
après ya peut-être un yann nepomniachi
dans l'autre bout de tableau maxime qui
est vraiment tombé dans un dans un bon
quart et un
ce que je vois des carrés avec kilian
nepomniachi mois de mourad lic en fait
assez dangereux vide leur shirov
radjabov fouillis fans et riga ici alors
radjabov fouillis fans ouais
et riga ici par avion à rennes on en
fait maxime est vraiment dans le dans le
bon tableau
le tableau f avec anish giri joué john
topalov ça doit ni à nantes ponk rate of
abdou cette europe galfond d'arrêt tata
du abdou tu as dû annonce
m qui joue contre pro 4 offres d'entrée
c'est pas simple ensuite il ya dingli
rennes qui avait battu millet
et six pianos bassam amine ça s'est un
peu en dessous mais cramique melkonian
c'est les deux sont dangereux et sarine
mammadov
année elle ça il est aussi dangereux
finale de pioncer quand parc st jacques
doit être
mieux mais ce que ces gagnants c'est dur
à dire
visuellement c'est gagnant pour les
noirs ça
en fait on va en arriver à ça d'une
manière x ou y est on va se faire
prendre le pion je pense qu'elle était
gagnante mais à analyser et s'il ya
d'autres gros joueurs français dans le
dans le tableau non non non non non
maxime est le seul joueur français à
participer et dans les joueurs français
un petit peu de premier plan il y à
aussi jules moussard qui avait tenté la
qualification une fois ou deux un peu à
larache mais rien de plus
sap a vraiment tenté sa chance côté côté
français
les joueurs français n'ont pas
globalement les joueurs français
n'aiment pas trop les compétitions sur
internet pour produire sa clairement
il ya un peu du maxsym ambulants qui
participent mais mais sinon
[Musique]
alireza arrêté bas qui aiment pas mise à
part les compétitions envie de ce type
title tous d sinon c'est pas trop sa
tasse de thé à notre bac y
est on et on acquis après jules à un peu
essayé par période mais c'est pas non
plus un gros joueur d'internet laurent
joue jamais il ya une ligue joue pas non
plus
christian bauer joue pas
donc
non les joueurs français sont pas trop
internet
globalement
oui les pubs qui sont là
parce qu bâche
qui tombe et ça fait plaisir de voir des
pubs
et très bien
l'état d'esprit qu'une tête de série
numéro 2 de son groupe après tête de
série global je sais pas
pas
on en a b c à
attends que les parties reprennent
normalement
je pense dans trois minutes
personnellement
ça me donneront peut-être le deuxième
tour qui sera sympa
mais en fait c'est fait lorsque j'ai vu
ça devait être à 28 mais je crois qu'en
fait il mettre le temps et il arrondit
c'est à dire que si c'était si les
parties sont finies à 22 ça reprend à
30,6 a fini à 18 ça va reprendre à 25 je
crois qu'ils arrondissent sur passion la
dizaine mais sur le las 2010 n
je regarde un peu le championnat du
monde jeune pas du tout il faut savoir
qu aux échecs les meilleurs jeunes ne
jouent pas les championnats du monde en
fait par catégorie en tout cas à partir
des catégories moins de quatorze
généralement
donc ce n'est pas une compétition qu'il
est très intéressant de suivre
l'alluré
champion du monde junior j'imagine
comment ce que j'ai raté quelque chose
ni google ni je parle de la catégorie
junior je parle pas dans les catégories
d'âge plus faible mais
plus plus basse
mais dans les joueurs
les joueurs jouent les tournois du top
en fait très rapidement
maxime une petite null null rapidement
on va déjeuner vite vite vite
aller il manque un demi-point auch et ce
sera la qualification
pour maxime
pas l'art en grande forme un maxime là
on va remettre la caméra vers les blancs
d'ailleurs on a oublié de le faire on va
passer et torride zagat avec les noirs
et on va remettre les noms comme il le
faut
voilà
alors moi si j'étais une touriste zagat
je ferai une petite berlinoise et une
petite nul j'en aurai marre de perdre
parce que c'est trop
après je pense qu'il va la jouer parce
que voilà
mais si c'était que moi
j'en aurai marre de me faire battre en
boucle comme ça
tellement dur
marque en effet pas exemple compter
français ouais bah oui oui non non les
meilleurs les joues pas généralement je
sais pas si marco matériel il joue
d'ailleurs j'ai pas vérifié donc c'est
pour ça que c'est pas une compétition
très intéressante à suivre
alors je comprend un que les joueurs
amateurs se rendent pas compte de ça et
pense que les championnats du monde
jeunes
ça fait découvrir les les plus les
futures stars mais c'est pas du tout cas
bon là c'est pas la partie de maximin
détrompez vous on va la fermer
attentes que sa part maxime la partie
maxime qui n'a pas encore débuté
pala parlait on voit de façon la caméra
que maxime n'a pas commencé
ah ouais mais
il est tranquille
ils ne font pas partir en même temps les
partys pas pourquoi
non
merci 20 janvier pour le club
je sais pas
ce qu'est ce que j'ai eu un bug ouais en
fait ya juste eu un bug désolé ça pas
lancer automatiquement
maxime a qui joue un petit p 3
alors là ça c'est vraiment des gosses
qui est en train de faire maxime
ouais c'est vraiment dégueu l'ouverture
de maxime
trop de trous mais bon il peut pas jouer
il veut pas jouer ces ouvertures y jouer
à larache
il est trop facile
une des deux suffire à lui nul sur les
sur une des sur celle là où la prochaine
ça fait gagner le match donc bon bein
il doit pas
doit pas être très stressés ils
joueraient pas pareil s'il y avait un
partout ça je peux vous le dire
prends le temps
50 pour maxime 13 20 pour ic torride
zagat
une grosse différence en termes de
grosses différences encore en terme de
temps mais ils torride zagat qui se met
comme comme dans les autres partis
il se mettrait très rapidement il se met
à réfléchir et
en fait dans la première partie s'est
mis à réfléchir un peu trop tard quand
il était déjà mal il a dû vouloir jouer
vite et il s'est dit on va essayer de
tenir le rythme de maxime et c'est un
petit peu du l'échaudé
maxime qui doit peut-être hésité à
peut-être des fois tu veux faire cavaler
b d2 qui on prend et des quatre pour
ouvrir le fou
maxime là qui en fait trop quand même
dans les ouvertures
c'est trop
original ce qui joue
après il s'occupait du cou
qui vont enfin un coup vite
je reste treize minutes allaient maxime
il faut aller la chercher cette qualif
il faut aller nous la chercher cette
qualif
vite et bien
il prépare puis on prend et des cats je
pense pour voir la position et faire
parler les fous
mes gars qui a décidé de se battre il
veut mourir les armes à la main
à maxime c'est terrible
je pense qu'il va prendre des 5 et
prendre des 5 et faire des quatre fers
dégâts directs
il peut pas on navigue garder la
structure comme ça il fait des quatre
direct c'est la même idée hein c'est de
s'ouvrir
maxime qui regarde un peu ses ongles
il est peinard
prises des 4 prises des 4
quatre prises des 4 ça ou la position et
b4 ça permet de garder la casse ces
quatre occupé par un pion et ça donne
pas au cheval basse que maxime va se
décaler en b2 avec la dame attention si
on échange les fous maxime pourrait
rester avec le move est fou contre le
bon fou ça pourrait être ça hein
un rapport matériel gênant
j'imagine
e3
bon ça ça va normalement jusqu'à un
échange à 5 puis on prend en plus on
prend
peut-être je veux faire tout reprendre à
8,2 me prend 1,8 et toi pour se gagner
la colonne à
paraît assez logique
ce qu'on peut dire c'est une occasion de
progresser ben non il veut jouer parce
qu'ils jouent mais
qui joue contre maxime tu te dis pas que
ça te fait enfin aux échecs tu dis pas
que tu veux une partie pour te faire
progresser à ce niveau là il joue parce
qu'ils jouent mais
il a peut-être une chance sur dix mille
encore de d'égaliser dans le match et
ils veulent apprendre c'est tout quoi
dire je suis déjà là machin j'ai rien à
faire de ma journée je tente quand même
ma chance
on s'est jamais
amusé clic une déco
huit dames à 8
apprendre du fou du coup pour pas donner
le tempo à la tour peut-être plus malin
de prendre du fou mais il prend vraiment
beaucoup de temps pour chacune deux des
six de ses décisions
eduardo je pense qu'ils joueraient plus
vite contre un autre joueur
mais à la contre maxime
c'est aussi le nom qui fait peur puis
les deux premières parties
la maxime qui a gagné la colonna
pourrait l'utiliser en jouant tour à 4
un jour pour taper le pion ou un tour à
sept pour venir taper damas de damas
brave eux il veut jouer le mauvais fou
conclut bons fous
bons joueurs de coin tu vois en vrai
c'est un bon joueur un de tout donner
pour essayer de revenir
maxime qui se posent peut-être des
problèmes à lui même dans le giron trop
facile
c'est peut-être ce qu'espère ithurritze
à garein
d'avoir un maxime qui vaut à bayer qui
voit comme ça très tranquille il doit
dire bon
il a gagné les deux premières mais
[Musique]
il a envie d'aller dormir
maxime en claquettes way
maxime en tongs chaussettes mais ça doit
suffire
il ya quatre minutes d'avancé déjà
ça échange qui haïssez 5 et là il va
sûrement y avoir à eux cinq ils veulent
dame
il veut dame g5 c'est peut-être bien
joué ça de la part des touristes saga
c'est fort ça
ça c'est fort
donc c'est vrai
noirs ici
peut-être qu'il va faire f3
juste
que maxime fogiel je pense pas un fou
lui demandait
ses passes il encore aux us
il a fait h3
il veut se garder la case pour le fou
l'ordinateur or fou prend 4 84 qui
arrivait trois cas y prend 1 mais c'est
très dur à voir parce qu'on n'aime pas
normalement
faire cet échange
je vous sais si ça permet de contrôler
la casa 4
c'est assez bien joué
maxime kiala
c'est un cas là on voit le problème de
maximin c'est ce fou le cavalier va
pouvoir venir en d4 s'il le veut il est
bien placé en c5
ce qui a valu à pas vraiment accès à des
cinq on n'arrive pas à échanger les fous
maxime peut perdre cette partie
alors il a vraiment joué à en pantoufles
celle la
salade maxime elle est vraiment bon toof
l'aide
il faudra pas réitérer ce genre de
performance contre séville en un c'est
bien c'est trop dangereux mais je pense
que maxime mettra les ingrédients
il va avoir du mal à la whey pour la
gagne et non mais ouais bon pour les
nuls il peut la tenir encore
mais pour la gagner il pourrait par
l'arnaqué salah je pense qu'elle est
trop
trop facile à jouer pour les noirs
je suis a pas de menace ça avec les
blancs
les pièces mineurs réussissent pas à
s'installer dans le jeu alors que le fou
c'est cissé lecavalier ces cinq sont
très forts
le problème
darty réfléchi parce qu'il ya pas
vraiment de coûts 1
faudrait peut-être venir en c2 ça lui
permettra de faire un joueur de focales
la tension ça peut menacer carrier prend
quatre points 4/4 et des premiers 4 qui
avait prévu 4 dame prend 3 comprend
trois fous prend 1,4 et c'est pour ça
que le fou est venu défendre
tu vas jouer tour eu un
f3
nous parlons à 50 sans ces trois là ce
niveau là ouais c'est dur de
[Musique]
c'est c'est difficile de se concentrer
en fait aux échecs maxime il sort quand
même des
du rapide et blitz de saint louis de la
sinne que phil cup
ça joue quand même énormément à haut
niveau et c'est difficile de tout le
temps être à cent pour cent surtout que
là ils mènent 2 0 dans un match où il
est nettement plus fort bond
l'horreur est pas forcément évident je
sais pas soit il est encore aux états
unis il est très tôt soit il est rentré
en france il doit être en jet lag
donc moi ça me paraît
ça ne choque pas qu'ils jouent à qui
joue très tranquille maxime après c'est
juste sur l'ouverture il aurait
peut-être dû être plus méfiant
et là et uri zagal 101 qui peut la
gagner après il aura encore les blancs
il peut encore espérer
joueur espagnol d'origine vénézuélienne
après peut-être maxime fait ça pour les
pubs un
toujours important les pubs
il va arriver faire rentrer sur la
colonne à la partie est
difficile
six veut revenir vers des 4 et ce qui
sera mieux placé
peut-être
bien sûr qu'il ya des cas du coup il se
fera pas touchés
17h46 ah ça je pense pas qu'il soit à
saint louis maxime du coup
parce que c'est volontaire de faire
autant de compet basse et lucratif 1 et
puis ça
quand tu fais une compet t'es pas
obligés de la gagner
donc là je sais pas combien ont gagné
les joueurs au premier tour mais ils
sont peut-être déjà à 4000 dollars ou un
truc comme ça
et puis à moi
deux cent mille ha le premier tour il
est quand même assez assez tranquille
il peut se permettre de jouer tranquille
où un
mais il joue parce que c'est lucratif
madame detroit il va peut-être x 4
on voit que m mais c'est de tout donner
pour se concentrer
détroit ya peut-être aussi dame b 2-1
lors du procès de faire cavalier 3 et
d'aller s'activer proche du roi adverse
forcément c'est le meilleur coin c'est
le coût de l'ordinateur
ex'im va tenter
on va avoir un c'est une option aux
cavaliers ou trois
pour vite vite vite arriver il fait la
même chose avec un valet g3 ça lui donne
peut-être des cavs a lieu deux dans
certains
dans certains monde et c'est là qu'ils
touriste zagat va craquer
et oui comme souvent maxime quand ils
s'activent il fait mal c'est là qu'ils
to ride zagat va va craquer ou peut-être
at-il déjà craqué de laisser ce contre
jeu à maxime
maître du contre jeu le joueur français
il a toujours un petit peu d'avancé
autant historique zagat qui a plus que 5
minutes maintenant c'est peu contre
maxime dans ce genre de position
maxime qui sifflote avril et il est très
très très très très facile maxime
lycées là qui vient de mettre un coup de
pression monumentale à tourine zagat
s'il tombe en dessous des 2 minutes avec
ce coup là après il aura dû beaucoup de
mal à jouer s'il a une autre décision
difficile à prendre
et à la déjà quatre minutes 4 minutes 30
le temps qui s'égrène l'ordinateur qui
proposait coup comme roy et fuite
peut-être pour revenir vers cette
protégée le pion ou damas est pour
gagner un tempo ici
peut-être même un coup comme damas est
intéressant pour venir un petit peu
touché la première rangée
le problème est assez que la décision
est difficile à prendre
et qu'il ne reste pas énormément de
temps à eduardo
eduardo qui su
bordeaux qui suit 3 3 43 30 je vais
d'ici tombe en dessous des 2 minutes ça
va être extrêmement dur pour lui mais ce
cavalier g3 il pose des problèmes donc
il fait g6
il veut empêcher cavaliers f5 mais
peut-être que maxime va maintenant venir
en e2 avec son cavalier
échanger les chevaux et faire un genre
de forteresse
peut aussi décider juste de temporiser
en juin coup droit
slicé dingue à différents niveaux entre
de gea mi-mars le problème en fait c'est
le titre gm il est donné beaucoup trop
bas en fait
pas du tout le même calibre de joueurs
les touristes zajac soit on le voit
ici à gros te
avait lieu devrait s'y perdre
le bénéfice de ce beau cavalier ça va ça
va rapprocher maxime de la nul et donc
de la qualification
et en plus il ya peu de temps
et contre 1 maxime qui tient tendent des
pièges à gauche à droite
et peut plus manger puis on mettrait sur
pied prend b3 en fait il veut dame prend
des 6 maxime
il va toucher le fou il va prendre 5
par an qui peut pas mais c'est que
c'est ce maxime se sont réorganisés en
fait le cavalier couvre des cases
et donc il réussit pas vraiment à sont
emparés de ce pion pour le moment
on le voit suez à la caméra il lève les
mains
il aimerait bien apprendre la victoire
maxime qui va prendre des six
c'est chose faite
qui va passer prendre 5 maintenant
c'est trop
trop dur
cavalia 5 ça a l'air d'être un joli coup
mais maxime d'après leur dis peut faire
nul direct peut faire danbury 3 cette
dame f8 avec un père pète imparable
c'est ce qui va faire
il peut pas faire rager sept îles se
feront dame prend des 5 et la dame et
fuite
et s'est terminé
il ya encore un échec en 23 mai droit va
se cacher et maxime qui s'étire et cif
et dames 3 damas est tjrs adam prend b4
et ce sera simplement punto de plus
et oui ça va qualifier sans aucun
problème
bah c'est pour ça qu'ils jouent aussi
facile hein et qui se permet d'ouverture
un peu moyenne parce qu'il sait que dès
qu'ils passent l'accélérateur quand il
est comme ça dominant dans un match à
2,0 maxime
la marge est elle là c'est même plus une
marge c'est comme vous et c'est même pas
un gouffre il ya un univers d'écart
entre les deux et torride zagat qui le
comprend il a eu sa position
l'ordinateur affiché du moins 3 pour lui
mais bon en deux coups de cuillère à pot
maxime a retourné la situation
il va peut-être même la gagner parce
qu'ils torride zagat va forcer le gars
c'est terrible
c'est terrible beaucoup trop fort maxime
il est écoeuré to ride zagat eduardo
elle est peut-être mieux à faire de sa
journée
que de se prendre une clé de bras et la
maxime qui va répéter un je vous annonce
professionnels ici
maxime qui se qualifie pour le prochain
tour sans avoir
sué la moindre seconde beaucoup trop
facile
c'est là c'est la prochaine fois
il peut continuer à jouer endormi un
maxime aura peut-être même pas besoin de
se réveiller il peut jouer depuis son
lit
attention ça me fait bien ce sera quand
même à une autre paire de manches
et pancrate of en plus qui domina nand
ah oui mais c'est pas son tableau à
maxime en fait ça qu'on a vu
ça absolument rien à voir avec maxime
a donc on en a vraiment absolument rien
à [ __ ] c'est pas du maxsym
attendre un de la confirmation mais je
crois que maxime est qualifié
et touristes d'un gars qui devait savoir
avant le match que la différence de
niveau et est importante
forcément il le sait
parce que quelqu'un
mais dans le chat
la situation il ya je ne sais pas
pourquoi ils restent en fait c'est pour
ça que que je me pose la question
maxime médard o que oui maxime sait
c'est un autre monde
avec ph ouvert à côté way
prochain match
qui sera une autre paire de manche
sa et maxime s'est déconnecté
on va pouvoir nous aussi
partir on se retrouvera j'ai pas la date
du prochain match encore
et deux ennemis il suffit à un deux et
demi il reste deux parties il reste une
partie pardon puisqu'il ya quatre partis
dans le match si maxime avait perdu la
prochaine ça ferait un an et demi deux
ans et demi un an et demi
la différence entre un joueur et a dit
c'est un génie c'est le travail le
talent et meilleures prépas c'est tout
en fait c'est juste ou
bon bah je vous dis
mince et il est pas bien pourquoi il
avait annoncé un truc maso maxime le
match était vraiment facile j'ai du
décalage min bravo à toi en tout cas
pour pour cette victoire et là je vois
tout s'est quasiment mais pas de
victoire noire a oui ça c'est sûr
pour les amis bravo à maxime encore pour
cette victoire ce sera une autre paire
de manches contre sam sevian là on a vu
que l'écart de niveau était à j'ai même
pas les mots là c'est ça jouez pas au
même jeu et on verra on verra ce que ça
donne pour maxime pour la suite je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi ce live et je
vous dis à très bientôt sur czech com/fr
pour la suite de cette compétition et
l'avancé de maxime dans le tableau ciao
ciao